this morning we were learning about new
evidence in the search for a gunman who
killed a seven-year-old girl in Houston
Harris County Sheriff released this
composite sketch of the suspect
yesterday he is wanted for shooting and
killing Jasmine Barnes as she wrote in
her mother's car last Sunday morning the
sheriff also revealed new surveillance
video Janet shamlian is outside of the
sheriff's office in Houston Janet good
morning good morning they refine the
suspect description now calling him a
thin white male in his 30s or 40s with a
5 o'clock shadow but stressing he may
have changed his appearance
the sheriff describes him as a cowardly
killer and is saying that law
enforcement will not rest until they
find him it's a whodunit right now in
addition to this suspect sketch the
Sheriff's Office released this video
Thursday of the gunman's red pickup
truck just before they say he shot and
killed second grader Jasmine Barnes once
I determine who did it then we'll
understand motive a little bit better
the family's attorney believes it was a
hate crime we do believe that it was
racially motivated in part because our
nation at this at this moment is a
highly racially charged Society look
Porsha Washington was driving daughter
jasmine and her three sisters to grab
coffee Sunday morning when the suspect
opened fire on their car Jasmine was
shot in the head and died immediately
her mom was hit in the shoulder I didn't
see anything but my but shattered glass
and bullets coming towards my car
Jasmine's 15 year old sister alexis is
the only one who saw the gunman what did
you see I just he was white any eye blue
eyes and I was it cuz he had a hoodie on
so I couldn't see his hair support for
the family is growing on twitter'
hometown NFL wide receiver DeAndre
Hopkins pledged to help pay for Barnes's
funeral and said he'll dedicate
Saturday's playoff game in her honor the
family is grateful for the support but
none of it can replace a daughter I
thank God that he did leave me 3 you
know that I do have 3 to look forward to
but at the end of the day they can't
replace their sister
the reward for the suspects arrest now
tops $100,000 there will be a community
rally here tomorrow to keep this in the
public eye and Jasmine will be laid to
rest on Tuesday
Anthony Thank You Janet a horrible thing
for a parent to have to say I still have
three